this isn't a scene from a wool zone or a
disaster movie
this is wennington an Essex Village
engulfed By Flames
last summer record temperatures caused
record fires across the country and
their Affairs this summer if there are
more our stretch services will struggle
to cope we know from last summer that
the UK managed to cope with the heat
waves that we experienced but this was
very much at a breaking point but if
these events are going to happen more
frequently and are going to be longer in
duration or going to see higher
temperatures we know that the UK is not
prepared for those types of scenarios
almost a year on the scars of last year
are yet to fade families lost everything
and locals are terrified of a repeat
this summer the forecast is that we are
going to have some absolutely scorching
days all the grass all the fields around
will be dry
it is
almost like I don't know living under a
guillotine and waiting for it to come
down hundreds of miles away in Scotland
days of hot weather bought days of fires
possibly the largest recorded ever in
the UK
a wildfire so big it can be seen from
out in space
but back on Earth just how prepared are
our officials a number 10 spokesperson
told Sky News the government and
emergency services are well prepared for
any future heat waves since last
Summer's hot weather we've worked across
government to identify and Implement
lessons
this included the UK Health security
agency's adverse weather and health plan
which contains guidance on extreme heat
and outlines how everyone can work
together to respond to heat waves
so weather lessons have been learned
we'll find out soon enough as the UK
braces for warmer weather in the coming
days and weeks Subway Chowdhury Sky News